hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking with major Neill
Franklin retired from the Maryland State
Police he's also the executive director
of Law Enforcement Against Prohibition a
group of cops law enforcement people
active and retired who fight against the
drug war and its policies Neil thanks
for talking to us now thanks for having
me you guys have created a great study
that's online at leaps website and you
delivered a copy of this to Gil
Kerlikowske the current drug czar what
what are you trying to accomplish one of
the first things we wanted to do was put
together a comprehensive look at those
past four decades which we'll focus upon
financial cost human cost addiction Neil
you were a certain point in your career
you were a drug warrior and that changed
what what happened to flip you on this
issue when I retired in 1999 I went to
work for the Baltimore Police Department
and just a few months after my
retirement date I had a conversation
with a comrade of mine Edward totally he
was telling me about a case he was
working he was going to make one final
buy of cocaine from the mid-level drug
dealer he was working with the FBI on a
task force right here in DC and as we've
had in the past we've had these
conversations and we didn't you know we
weren't thinking about the inherent
danger or the possible danger it's
October 30th I got a phone call late one
night woke me up and it was a co-worker
saying that it totally had been shot
excuse me
so my wife and I get in to the car and
we drive down the PG in General Hospital
and it's too late what had happened when
the dealer it had driven the dealer to
the location to get their drugs the
dealer came back to the car supposedly
with the drugs and he pause for a moment
to extinguish the cigarette and soon as
he did that he reached in the car and
shot ed totally at point-blank range in
the head and it was that moment you know
that night and those weeks after and
those months after where I just said
what are we doing and I started thinking
about the other officers that I knew
that had died in just a couple of years
after that more officers in Baltimore
City were dying from drug crime you know
dealers the prohibition part and that's
when I made my turn
that's when I stumbled across leaps
website when looking for this
information in his research trying to
find others who think like I do what is
the best way to honor the death of
officer totally and people like it the
best way that we can honor them is to
completely dismantle this system of
prohibition and implement a new system
focused on treatment and education
period we know it we know that needs to
be done why don't we just do it what are
the big round numbers or the findings of
the war on drugs what what has it been
doing and what has it been how has it
been affecting American society when we
first started the war on drugs we only
had a few hundred thousand people in
prison today we're somewhere around 2.5
million people in prison over those 40
years we put over 39 million people in
prison and a vast majority of those are
from nonviolent drug offenses call that
that's things like simple possession
yeah
no level dealing right we're not talking
about kingdoms and even though we've
arrested a few we're looking at 1.3
trillion dollars spent on law
enforcement efforts we're talking about
cops judges judicial system in prisons
as quite costly when you look at the
number of bodies look at Mexico over the
past five years alone since we stepped
up efforts in assisting Mexico in
fighting back against the cartel you're
looking at over I think the number sound
like 38,000 people murdered at the hands
of the KOAT cartel in Venezuela it's
even more in our very own country in our
neighborhoods and in our communities
every year somewhere between five to
eight thousand people murdered at the
hands of a neighborhood gang
why do police chase push back against
the drug war as it's currently
constituted what's it doing to their
efforts to actually control crime you
have to think about the history of how
local police got involved in this in the
first place it came from the federal
government in the form of funding we
were and I sometimes I usual we bribed
into getting into this war many police
agencies now continued to balance their
budgets through federal funds through
grants firm grants and what have you and
and to lose that money would be
significant and you will hear some
police chief speak to that so and yet
they're against the war on drugs well
they say that it's failed that it's not
working
they just haven't taken the next step to
move away from it to really end it and
so that they continue they feel
pressured politically and sometimes you
can't blame them but because they care
about their jobs politically they're
pressured to toe the federal party line
what are the things that we can do
quickly and immediately to redress that
to start fixing it and get out of this
war mentality so immediately where you
don't need any legislative action
whatsoever the president can move
marijuana from a Schedule one category
down to a three or four and that would
mean I mean currently marijuana is
scheduled under drug class federal drug
issues was having no medical value
absolutely and then we that's already
been proven wrong with the with the 15
states that are now moving in Medical
Marijuana and with the many doctors
behind that but in doing that in
completely removing it from the schedule
system whatsoever then he gives the
authority then to the states to move and
to begin to develop models to manage
marijuana within their communities and
the next important thing is it's now
time for a discussion not a debate
that's been done the discussion as to
what are the best possible models how
can we manage these dangerous drugs
within our communities we already know
that prohibition does not work so now we
have to regulate and control let's have
your discussion come up with some
solutions we've also been down this road
before in the 70s you know we heard
stories that philip morris had
trademarked names like Acapulco gold and
Maui Wowi anticipating the legalization
of marijuana Jimmy Carter seemed to be
weeks away before a big scandal broke
and pulled back from legalizing drugs in
any way shape or form other countries
have decriminalized Portugal as
decriminalized drugs but are we actually
at a different stage of the discussion
over the drug war completely different
than back in the 70s for a number of
reasons number one we didn't have the
data that we have today prison numbers
financial numbers body count we didn't
have those numbers when you look at the
leaders from Mexico the former
presidents have come out with the
Commission just a couple weeks ago in
their report yeah we have Republican
people running for the Republican
presidential nomination Senator Ron Paul
absolutely but here's another
significant part they didn't have leap
they didn't have Law Enforcement Against
Prohibition back in the 70s and we're
making a significant difference because
we bring a completely different
perspective we've been on the frontlines
we've been out there in this battle and
we can speak from that perspective
letting people know that this is a
complete failure what is the best way
both for civilians and lawn
forcement to find out more about leap
well they can go to
cops say legalize drugs dot-com and we
have a brand new website up very
comprehensive with some very good
information and they really should visit
that site major Neill Franklin retired
Maryland State Police executive director
of leap Law Enforcement Against
Prohibition thanks very much for talking
to us thanks Nick I'm Nikhil SP for
Reason TV